after I got moved to Alexandria Virginia
I was in solitary the whole time so 10
and a half months they said it was for
covid and then they said it was for my
protection but the thing is is that when
they transferred me to other locations
they'll put me in general population
so then that goes right out the window
these reasons go right out the window I
think personally that it was more so
about trying to break my spirit than it
had anything to do with trying to keep
me safe or you know keeping covid at a
minimum or whatever you were in solitary
confinement for ten and a half months
ten and a half months how did you
keep any of your wits about you and that
seems it seems like torture
um God my shamanic breathing techniques
prayer meditation
um
and
that's pretty much it I mean I
experienced some miraculous things in
solitary